yeah but like again like because you
know i've also been thinking of like
getting
you know aft after what i'm going
through because i'm right i'm in a
really busy period but like
once i've like settled down and i can
actually start doing twitch streams more
regularly it's like
all right i want to try and figure out a
way to not make this another job
right you know what i mean because it's
like i've already done it with anime
where like
all literally all of last year and like
a large majority of 2019
admittedly i didn't [ __ ] watch any
anime because i was so
[ __ ] burnt out on it right after like
six plus years of talking about it yeah
and it's like and it's and it's shitty
because it's like i still love it
but like i had so much trouble actually
sitting down and being like i'm gonna
casually watch an anime
yeah because i can't do it you're gonna
be like ranked watching hentai
right i can't play i can't play casual
hentai anymore i
only have ranked playlists oh dude it's
like it's ripping my [ __ ] libido
i do kind of feel that because it's not
ranked ten times
but like you do you like you do watch
anime and you're just like
is this is this useful to like my job
getting out literally like ranked in
casual gaming yeah if you only play rank
it's so hard to play normal games
it's like it's like i could be making a
video on this yeah and if i don't
i feel like it's voice to myself what
about when you go to like 7 11 right now
you're like [ __ ] i want to make a video
but i just want to get a sandwich but
[ __ ] i should vlog
oh my god i always feel that all the
time like i always end up taking
videos and photos at 7 11 even if it's
just like in the middle of the night and
i'm getting a strong b-roll there yeah
yeah i do and that's how i always think
which is like kind of i think unhealthy
i just want to live
in the moment and like drink my like
three strong zeros and just like
like pass the [ __ ] out but but i'm also
like well look at how aesthetic it is
and i'll like have to like take
some b-roll and i'm like i'll definitely
use that at one point or whatever
but oh it's also a trap right like cause
7-eleven will come out with something
new like literally every three or four
days now yeah
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] now i want
stop being a great company with great
new
items for me as a customer yeah because
like like the seasonal products in japan
they're just like this is just like a
youtube gold mine yeah yeah because it's
it's
like japan is a it is it is i mean don
quixote was
made for youtube it really was it's like
do you are you running out of video
ideas go to don quixote yeah yeah just
inspired yeah it's not just that but
like i think japan as a country is just
optimized for every kind of [ __ ]
content out there oh yeah my god i've
never seen a country that is more
aesthetic than japan
it's kind of not fair like you did you
were talking about this the other day
yeah
yeah yeah because we were like walking
down what like was it nakamura
yeah and it was just like this random
street in this random area and i'm just
looking around being like
that's really [ __ ] aesthetic isn't it
my god
god out loud to me was like i hate
how aesthetic japan is like literally
every i can turn any corner
and i'm just like damn that looks good
really yeah
i feel like because you know like for
example when you go to starbucks in the
uk i feel like this is ruining the
architecture like
there's such like classical buildings
that look great it's like oh it's
fantastic
and japan they look really [ __ ] cool
and japan is so good at decorating
everything yeah starbucks they've like
they have like 100
like figured everything out yeah yeah
everyone is obsessed with starbucks
right yeah and it's like they're so good
like all the sakura cups right now like
everything's sakura yeah they change it
next month it's gonna be something
else it's like they've gained it so well
yeah and it's just like every little
restaurant even if it's just like a
local restaurant
or like a big chain they've like
personalized their looks so much that
you know you go you can go to a
different restaurant and have like a
completely different experience and
it's just kind of ruined like i don't
know
if ruin is the right word but like it's
it's set my expectations
unreasonably high for when i go back to
england and everything kind of looks
like you've been to the uk i've never oh
i have once i went once for this like
sony
uh square enix uh sponsored thing i
think it was like a
a vr before vr was perfect just dropping
the big names just like you're like
pokemon
it was before vr was perfected so
everybody threw up everywhere
i think it was like a really big problem
from family guy i was just [ __ ]
vomiting
um it was not that fountainy but yeah it
was really similar
uh it made everybody sick and yeah yeah
but um
that was the only time i ever went and i
was so in love with it
everything was so lovely and beautiful
is the architecture fantastic
i thought so [ __ ] you he thinks it
doesn't look good
i mean like coming to japan i'm like
japan's way more aesthetic than the uk
i think i think i think tokyo building
is like ugly sometimes they're like
really messy
and like dirty sometimes i don't know it
depends on the district yeah
yeah it depends on the district yeah
there are some parts where i'm just like
yikes this is like kind of gross
what did you like about the uk i'm
curious um let's see our hotel
was a very like classical hotel you're
very lucky
yeah oh yeah i know i was lucky um and i
loved
the breakfast oh my god the breakfast
was phenomenal
english breakfast oh so to be fair
english breakfast is good
amazing and um you know everybody kind
of kept to themselves
yeah that's really good people do like
that i like that i like that it's it's
not british people keeping to themselves
it's americans
unable to keep this this is this is why
i feel like when i moved here i feel
like there's a lot of parallels between
japanese and british culture like the
way that it's like keep yourself don't
make noise
head down yeah don't worry about it
don't don't talk on public transport
don't do that
why would you do that don't do that yeah
maybe that's why i just like innately
really liked it but you know like you
said before japan
does kind of have this like romantic
weird
admiration with europe so i think i mean
culturally
i guess like personality-wise we're also
the same keep to ourselves like be quiet
but there's a lot of things i think in
japan that like wanted to be like the uk
yeah right yeah i feel like the uk were
pretty good at knowing when to
be loud and all rowdy i guess yeah at
least i feel like real but i don't know
what was the drink i had
pims
is good honestly i i [ __ ] with favorites
it's good it's like a summer cocktail
drink where you put like a bunch of
fruit in a
drink and it's like a ten percent
alcoholism it's quite strong yeah
kind of like a long island iced tea
fruity no no no don't say long island i
see you okay
like a super super fruity and fresh
tasting cocktail that's
quite strong tastes good every everyone
tastes good no it doesn't matter is what
you take when you get [ __ ] and if you
go to a british barbecue
everyone brings pims yeah yeah it's very
normal sounds great that was delicious i
had it like every night
um and then you know you'd like feel
better with the breakfast in the morning
yeah but yeah i it was really lovely i
wanted to go again but they were like
there's no timing and whenever i had
like vacation time i'd always choose
japan
[Music]
i'm sorry i was curious what people
think about the uk because obviously
when you're british you're like [ __ ]
hate you're here i mean as well
to be british as a sherlock holmes
i [ __ ] myself like it was did you did
you go to baker street
no i didn't because the the the
underground station for baker street has
like
um all the walls like in the shape of
like outlines of uh the characters like
on like and tiles yeah it's pretty
oh really yeah yeah so a lot of those
the really historic stations
all the underground stations have like
something to have for it like i think um
where the globe theater is it's a bunch
of shakespeare stuff all over the
underground station
wow that's lovely japan kind of does
that too in a sense but a lot more like
subtle i feel like i think yeah we're
really proud of our history in britain i
think
yeah it probably shouldn't be at some
time
but some things are good they're like
shakespeare okay forget the colonization
stuff
because like for me at least as a brit i
feel like london is pretty cool
london's a cool city um but sorry i feel
like i always bring up
i just love hearing what people think
about uk it's really interesting
yeah of course i care about what people
think about japan yeah yeah yeah well
let me
tell you okay no i mean like
london's cool london's like really
different i feel though london's like
kind of in its own bubbles
totally different you go out of london
and like to me every every kind of place
in england kind of feels the same i mean
like
i would say i do kind of miss the
countrysides of england countryside's
really [ __ ] beautiful
um but for me i just don't get any
variety in england
right and that's what i love about japan
i feel i can get so many different
experiences here
and i can you know i i feel like
especially in covert times when we have
been stuck in japan
even even in those times i feel like
i've been able to
be blessed with a lot of variety in the
experience i've
had even being stuck in one country and
i feel like if i was living in any other
country
i would be way more bored than i am oh i
can't imagine
[ __ ] being in lockdown in australia
right now because it's like
dude there's nothing to [ __ ] do if
you don't have a car like and you're not
even allowed to like drive around right
like i can't walk anywhere
right so it's like well [ __ ] what am i
going to do look at the [ __ ]
same cockatoo 70 days in a while what is
a cockatoo
you know what cockatoo is a bird it's a
yeah it's a giant bird yeah
don't think that sounds badass to you i
mean
they're parrots so yeah i mean trained
ones can
i watched a tick tock of like a cockatoo
sing a song by itself when the owner
goes away and it was amazing yeah
which is like a kind of smaller cockatoo
yeah and like we taught it to sing the
adams family theme song
that's so cute and uh imitate the
microphone uh sorry the microwave
like the microwave beeping noises so
like it got so good to the point where
like
it would make beeping noise of the
microwave and i legitimately thought
someone was using the microwave oh my
god
like every now and then like he'd make
the microwave like
like the button pressing sounds that's
right and one of us would go into the
kitchen be like
he's using the microwave yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] cool there'll be an episode of
like
joey's haunted uh microwave coming up on
i feel an aura oh he used to make like
the phone ringing as well
oh my god because we used to have like
uh we used to have still like a landline
like you know phones yeah my parents
still do and uh and yeah it would
imitate
that sound so it's so many times during
the day we think the phone is ringing
and we'd walk in and it's not ringing
so annoying it got very annoying